[Music]
it must
ow
hey babe have you seen my do you think
we should get a dog
wait we don't have any time you're in
the toaster all day oh yeah I guess
that's true there are a lot of work yeah
and so these are they locked it yeah and
then um it might be too hard if I quit
all baby toaster but whoa
and the Ducks eats the babies it's just
like we didn't get it oh my god babies
no honey honey honey honey don't cry we
didn't get a dog Oh would you still love
me if I had though crust yes Oh would
you still love me if I was purged yes
would you still love me of a peanut
butter yes okay yes okay oh I'm looking
thick oh here you are can be sure my dad
hmm
I'm gonna give you some of it yeah I'm
gonna give you a piece of it oh yeah
come to me you gonna be my french toast
yeah toast not in the mood Mexican oh I
have that for lunch
how about pizza burgers a burger at
steak for breakfast
oh yeah I forgot I love your sin yeah
you smell that burning OH
[Music]
at a supermarket and the deli go it was
like is that bull and I was like that's
not mold yeah have I told you this
before - twice 50 times shall we go out
tonight let's see we should quit our
jobs
yeah let's create jobs a move to the
beach yeah yeah and then we'll barter
for everything we need yeah
Corporate America yeah capitalism ffs
yeah we'll do that tomorrow yeah
no not this guy I hate this guy why you
love the scarf
olena universe where love means I did
hate oh come on it's the scarf
[Applause]
[Music]
hey I toss you up awake do you tell each
other apart
it must be it must be
it's ears
can see
as for me it must